if you're gay great fine no problem we
totally have no issues with that at all
if you follow the podcast you know my
history what I you know I so I'm very
comfortable with that but I don't see
people on Twitter in their profile
saying part of the straight community
you know you don't see in Pro you
understand what I'm saying like it's
like the reason that there's BET right
because black people needed a voice
whenever that started in the 70s now if
you had w-e-t White Entertainment
Television now we got a problem it's
just and I agree with that I don't think
there should be a white entertainment
because they dominated uh media for
whatever but I think that is more part
of the division that's happening that
that that feeds into it now don't get me
wrong I think there's there's I'm all
about anybody that's very proud to be
Mexican proud to be Guatemalan proud
like Ricky's Michoacan I love people
that are proud of their Heritage proud
to be you know Middle Eastern Jewish
whatever you are I have a lot of respect
for that I like I think Heritage and
tradition is powerful but from the
standpoint of because I am this I'm more
important than you I'm more I need to be
heard more than you and you know trying
to convert the way it's being done today
I'm not with it that data itself concern
should concern every single parent
in America that data that Bill Maher
showed if you've not seen it that data
that Bill Marshall showed everybody
who's a parent ought to be concerned
about that data today let me give you
two quick points um what happens is
people who are marginalized let's what
let's say it's the black community or
the gay community or the Jewish
Community they start off saying hey we
need a voice like we're getting drowned
out here we're being marginalized we're
being discriminated against like my dad
who grew up in Detroit would tell me
when he grew up in Detroit it used to
say signs no blacks no Jews no dogs okay
straight up that's what he grew up with
in the 50s all right so you develop a
voice but then what happens is once your
voice comes comes a little bit louder
let's say it's the lgbtq community let's
say it's the BET Community now you
become part of the mainstream and now
the mainstream says all right well I
don't I'm not LGBT what just happened
here but because you start off as a
small voice and you become part of the
mainstream pop culture now you're you're
in the ecosystem of pop culture
the second part because there's
someone's probably watching it's like
what is Catalina and AOC and political
divisions have to do with LGBT and the
Common Thread there is whether it's
nature versus nurture and to the bill
Mars point is that what essentially is
happening is now the debate is over this
is no longer part of nature it's now
being part of nurture whereas one
percent of people Baby Boomers Were Gay
and then two percent of or four percent
of Gen X
um and then Millennials now it's five
percent gen Z is now it's 10 20 it's
like hold on clearly an indoctrination
is is happening and that's essentially
the Common Thread there my issue is that
it's being pushed by these Millennial
young teachers at such a young age and
parents don't even have a voice
sometimes but also the fact that it's
influencing legislation if you have
0.01 of the population or the statistic
on on transgenders for example and then
now p people are forced to have one
bathroom or a transgender bathroom it is
influencing legislation on such a mass
scale because it's being pushed by the
far left so much that that does impact
the rest of the country why are these
small voices dominating policy you can't
even get policies passed for for veteran
health care that quickly but you can get
transgender bathrooms pushed on a
federal level in some cases that's
ridiculous to me so how do we solve it
so what's the solution so if you're if
you're saying what you're saying what is
a solution parents need need to have a
voice at the school level they need to
stop this at that level and say teachers
your job is to teach my child math
social studies gym whatever and to take
your political culture War opinions out
of the classroom and then parents need
to have need to educate their kids on
what's going on in a thoughtful way so
that they're not being it's part of the
culture now
so okay so parents uh run for school
board run for school board but okay so
say you do that what else is the
solution though Tom what is there really
so I guess that's the question I'm
trying to ask is there really a solution
or is it in too deep
have they already uh gotten so deep into
universities and school systems that to
be able to shift this is going to take a
decade or two and if you do how do you
do it well this is exactly the problem
you know you have
um the far left that is influencing the
kids because they want to tell the kids
what to think they do not want the
children to be guided culturally by the
parents they feel that they should guide
the children culturally and they feel
that um people call it grooming people
call it whatever you want
that's the issue and she's right but
this is good this is a decade-long fight
because it took a while to get here and
people are waking up to it what happens
is Mark Twain said the fog comes in on
little cat feet you don't really hear it
but the fog comes in and what has
happened here over the last 20 years
there has been a steady March toward the
schools bringing in content that is
increasingly left culture at the public
school level that's where they're
driving it in Dallas two of the biggest
private schools that you would say they
are probably
a tick conservative they're not
religious schools but both of them have
What's called the safe room where you
can go in and have a discussion about
being gay experimenting gender confusion
which they don't call a confusion and
they will not tell your parents
will not tell your parents so your child
like this young woman this 13 year old
you were talking about confused for a
year could be sitting there constantly
having these conversations in a safe
room and they don't tell the parents so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]